introduce yourself hello my name is uh
shindo el and i
do a manga
what kind of manga what kind of manga
yeah there we go there we go
there we go
is that how you introduce yourself uh to
you know
some fellows of the public who might not
be so familiar with your work i used to
i just used to say ero mangaka and then
people started saying you don't have to
say little poet
[Laughter]
manga or smile that's mine
what do you say when they ask oh what
kind of series you draw oh i haven't
heard of you uh
oh then i go yeah
okay okay
they normally just stop there they're
like i kind of get it i'm not gonna push
too much on this uh some people do some
people
yeah yeah yeah it's like the same it's
like you know like porn directors who
are just like i'm a pawn director you
could have just said
yeah you could have just sent you made
movies that's fine
yeah i think uh it's fair to say i know
the least
about you and your work i think these
two know the most yeah but i'm sure
there are many viewers who also are in
the same position as me where they saw
your name in the title and they're like
i don't really know what it is that you
do so is there some series that maybe
the viewers might know and if not i
guess you'll they'll get an insight into
uh the life of an arrow mangaka today
well when you when i got invited to uh
talk on trash taste i did some homework
oh
and i saw the episode where you guys
read my uh engine yeah
that the authors and makers
[Laughter]
i have no words okay i guess we'll jump
right into it okay you created
metamorphosis right very very popular in
the communities
definitely the most infamous united st
of all time i would say especially in
the western community
i've said something about it that i do
actually i i do regret saying really
wonderful
now you know
so too faced
videos on it haven't changed there's one
thing that i think i did just get
massively wrong
i i in the episode i think i said
something along the lines of like um it
seemed unrealistic that the mum would
blame the daughter for the dad oh yeah
right
i think and then i found out it's
totally not unrealistic and that it's
happened a bunch and that i lost a lot
of faith in humanity when i thought yeah
yeah i thought i [ __ ]
who would have thought i feel like this
is just my child innocent brain i'm like
no a mother would never blame them so
okay
so so i guess we should
this is this is like a trash taste first
never before has a guest come on and
said heard you were talking [ __ ]
should we explain i guess what i'm going
to monetize immediately now uh what
metamorphosis is
kind of very
if someone asks you like oh you know
i've heard this metamorphosis thing
henshin thing like but i've never read
it could you like sell it to me like
what what is it about
god it's like
the queen for dream but like manga
that's probably that's probably the best
way to explain it that is honestly how i
would explain it as well yeah i believe
i said something very similar on like
the podcast episode where we described
it where i was like yeah it kind of
reminds me of red queen for a dream
where
it's just really depressing but also
there's a lot of sex in it yeah it's
like wrinkling
yeah
but it was only that scene
that's probably the best way to explain
it
i literally the last time i read it was
that episodes i'm trying to remember
what happens it's like a high school
girl meets a guy on the street and then
they hook up and have sex in a yeah and
like in a karaoke
yeah yeah i feel like why am i trying to
explain your flight
like tell me if i'm right here
and it just keeps escalating and
escalating yeah yeah yeah
so like
very adult by the way okay i guess i
guess we're jumping right into it yeah
okay like how did you come up with that
i just got i just got asked what what
like what were your inspirations in
writing that it's a trope right like the
first of all it's the uh makeover trope
yeah the girl takes off the glasses and
she's hot right yeah yeah yeah
and then there's the uh the garuka like
turning into a giant into a gutter yeah
and that's i've never done that before
so i'm like let's try it out
and it worked out pretty well that's how
it turned out yeah
damn did you know how like the story was
going to develop before you started
working on it or was it just something
because it's it's like pretty it's a
pretty long story in terms of like a lot
of
a lot of error manga compared to you
know some one shorts or you know one or
two chapters but this one was
volume yeah it was a full volume like
did you have everything planned out from
the get-go or did it kind of develop
everything planned out but i
think i said in the afterward that i had
the ending out
before i started right i think i just
and i was talking to my editors about it
and they asked you know so how does it
end i'm like well i just want her to die
at the end and they're like oh
spoilers by the way
i forgot that happened yeah i think i
was so traumatized at the thing before i
was like what the [ __ ] yeah i feel i
feel like her unfortunately dying was
like one of the high points because
like her suffering had ended by that
yeah
right and that's like did you did you
always know you wanted it to be that
depressing or like i mean like i wanted
i wanted it to be more depressing but my
editor was like you want to speak you
have to put like a little bit of levity
in it i'm like
wait oh hold on what what what did you
have to cut that would have made it more
depressing like
well i couldn't put as many like drug
scenes as i wanted to right right
because like in the magazine because it
gets published in an uh monthly magazine
right right right
and in the magazine they had to like
cover up all the uh drug bits oh so like
a syringe had to be like kind of like a
blue on it oh okay
i had the whole like you know like
cooking up the
cooking up the drugs yeah yeah and
they're like you can't do that
oh damn because like the cops are
already kind of
tough on manga yeah yeah yeah yeah and
they don't want like
you know more pressure right
right because it's it was certainly rare
to see
like drug use in just like even
aeromongo
manga in general and it was such a heavy
theme which i think is like super super
rare to see you know in in any kind of
media that comes out from japan right i
think insane and manga you see some drug
use
or something yeah yeah but in uh hentai
it's
mostly like
i don't know what it is it's right now
it's like
it's like aphrodisiac aphrodisiac
um hypnosis apps and stuff yeah
you have a smartphone yeah
yeah you are now horny
see because i again i didn't know
anything uh about you the the only work
i'd read was was metamorphosis and i i
guess i didn't know when they were like
oh shinuel's coming on i'm like oh did
she shouldn't else speak english
i didn't even know right i didn't know
anything dude i guess when you made
metamorphosis do you find that your
experience is from like uh because you
were raised in the u.s right yeah does
that have a lot of effect on how you
write manga or is it still very like
japanese i don't know i think
because i i've been told that it's not
japanese it's right like my storytelling
but like
i tried to make it japanese yeah yeah
and um i don't know if my
experiences in new york really help me
[ __ ] but like
you know i try not to like
directly put that into my storytime yeah
yeah it would kind of be like
alien to most japanese readers i'm just
projecting all the florida man stuff
i've seen
you see a florida thing right that's
going to be in one of those i mean i'm
sure that's also the case considering
that i think like for a lot of japanese
people new york is kind of like seen in
this like glory light type of like you
know like new york wow you know like
like glitzy new york or like 80s new
york where it's like yeah yeah like you
know
everyone gives a [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
exactly oh my god just metamorphosis man
did you expect it to be as like big i
didn't expect it to be like so me me
yeah right yeah yeah i i knew of the
image of her whereas the glasses yeah
yeah as an anime fan
there's some images that are like almost
iconic yeah and one of them is the girl
with the glasses yeah yeah oh if you
know you know yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh my god yeah did you like when you
released it was it something that
immediately got like picked up by the
community or was it something that you
know you released and you know you had
the usual reaction and then over time it
just blew up in popularity and it was an
overtime thing because like when it was
in the magazines it was
because the editors didn't want to put
it up front because it's kind of like
chilly yeah yeah yeah so he was always
at the back
damn
trying to push it under the rock
so it's kind of low-key for a while
until like like people um i think online
just picked it up
yeah and started memeing on it yeah
because i remember when i when i
interviewed you like three or four years
ago uh i asked like if you know like the
memes and you were like oh yeah i'm very
upset
because it's just like i don't know like
do you write do you think like the memes
like kind of
i don't know take away from like the the
the message that you were like trying to
portray in metamorphosis or do you think
just like kind of just like no i enjoy
the memes it's whatever that means fine
i don't really
like i don't think about
putting out a message when i make a
story right right you know just like you
want to talk about all that yeah i mean
like
i just wanted to make it entertaining
first and foremost yeah
but i think a lot of i felt
entertained or something yeah
yeah
but i think i think though like you know
regardless i think like a lot of people
read metamorphosis and was like
there's some there's some hidden message
here there's like some kind of like
deeper meaning like to this like story
because it's just so different to the
standard dozens you would read right
like yeah you know the normal doji is
just like boy meets girl boy fox girl
yeah that's kind of it you know i mean i
would say like out of every you know um
error doesn't i've seen or error manga
like i was probably like the most
invested in any like story as i was in i
wasn't as invested in any other story as
it was metamorphosis in terms of just
seeing the characters develop
in
in the development that you gave them
and just you know
every like a lot of things outside of
just
the hentai scenes and the sex scenes and
everything
i was probably invested in in the
characters and the ending and that also
also made me even more invested in the
aero scenes as well i thought that was
like fantastic you know i don't know how
much of it was planned on your ends but
it was
it was absolutely incredible well as
long as there's like a seal of a story
in there i think people will pick up on
it yeah yeah yeah yeah cause like you
know a lot of hentai i think especially
since maybe
early uh 2000s
they've been streamlining it to make it
more like like i don't know fappable
yeah you know like like they just jump
straight into the [ __ ] and i'm just
like come on come on guys like there are
some dozens i've read where i'm like i
feel like i've skipped like five pages
yeah yeah because there's a no build up
yeah when i when i open a dozen it's
like page two or like the first one page
one come on guys yeah page one and
they're already [ __ ] i'm like whoa
whoa chill out leaves me into this [ __ ]
goddamn like i'll take that over the
hentai that start with like three
minutes of text explaining
who thought that was a good idea no but
like some people are super into that
right it's like
yeah they are like what this it's just
like it's like star wars text on yeah
because some movies just start out with
the commandments yeah yeah it's
happening
it's the same people who enjoy you know
the interview sections at the start of
porn right like
they want to like get into the story
beforehand it's like i want to feel
invested in this yeah i i have noticed
another trend that's uh i've seen a lot
of um era manga recently or just not
even recently it's just like it's like
you know like where they say the most
important part of a youtube uh video is
the first 14 seconds yeah so like
there's some error manga that start off
with just like the [ __ ] for like the
first three pages and then it goes to
the story like you gotta hook the
viewers yeah it's always like page one
they're [ __ ] and then it's like this
is how it happened
there's like an omega algorithm